since the release of 2008 fireman
multiple writers tech experts and
financial wizards have worked hard to
find out just how much money Tony Stark
spent being Iron Man some of these
numbers are surprisingly low and some of
them are straight-up astronomical but
one thing's for certain being the iron
Avenger ain't cheap
in 2010 the same year Iron Man 2 was
released IO nines and Ally knew it's
crazy numbers and learn at the total for
all parts comprising Iron Man suits came
to around 100 million dollars Nuits
pointed out that this was around 12
million less than the cost of an f-35
fighter plane you probably wouldn't find
them in a big-box store but
hypothetically it wouldn't be out of the
reach of the US military the story is a
decade old so why aren't there already
fleets of Iron Man suits well probably
because of a couple of the stories
missing pieces first Nuits comes to the
figure with only five components of the
hypothetical suit a helmet-mounted
display an exoskeleton a portable
nuclear power source a jetpack and
wearable computers no weapons are
mentioned which are crucial to being
Iron Man there are many other missing
suit capabilities like Tony's waist
filtration system you know the question
I get asked most often is Tony how do
you go to the bathroom to just soak a
second even if it were a complete list
the story is missing a critical
component the research and development
necessary to make all these different
pieces of tech work together in one suit
that kind of brainpower come to the
hefty and the knowable price tag a
couple of months after the 2012 release
of Avengers money supermarket comm
against a cost of being Iron Man a much
steeper some than I oh nines quote a
slight estimator the cost of living as
both Tony Stark and Iron Man would be
well over 15 times greater putting it at
one point six billion dollars and like
the 2010 story money supermarket comm
stator took into account things like the
anti-personnel guns on the suits
shoulders $400,000 siege of rockets and
the wrists which would clock in at 1.5
million dollars and the developments of
the artificial intelligence program
known as jarvis at around 10 million
dollars money supermarket gates the
total cost for all of Tony Stark suits
combined by the end of the Avengers a
1.5 billion dollars the site's also went
beyond the suits and looked at Tony's
lifestyle they put his mansion at 25
million dollars and his fancy car
collection of 3.4 million dollars so
while most of that one point six billion
dollars goes to war suits its
- no he gives himself a modest amount of
cash to just have a little fun a little
less than a year after money supermarket
comm released its data putting the cost
of being a man at 1.6 billion dollars
the same site released a new estimate of
10 billion dollars by 2013 Starks
collection of suits increases from 7 to
42 adding seven billion dollars to this
estimate and honestly that's probably a
little low their data only counts 7 of
Tony's 35 new suits I'm on threes final
battle and Tony's house party protocol
clearly shows way more than 7 new suits
so which 7 suits cost 7 billion dollars
you can likely add around 30 billion
dollars to the total and whatever that
total is well that's what Tony throws
away our Mantic gesture to pepper by
ordering a surviving suits to
self-destruct only to have new suits
ready to go buy a beggar's age of Ultron
there's one big ticket item that just
about everyone forgets in their
assessment of Tony's spending Veronica
aka the Hulkbuster suit the whole team
is down you got no backup here I'm
calling a Veronica
in particular there's the method of the
Hulkbuster suits delivery when Tony
activates her Annika and 2015's Avengers
age of Ultron we learn he isn't keeping
the armor in stark tower or a compound
in upstate New York the Hulkbuster armor
waits in orbit to be deployed by a
satellites that means that along with
developing and building the suits
veronica needed to be attached to a
satellite which needed to be launched
into orbit so while we can't tell you
how much it would cost Tony to build the
Hulkbuster armor we do know launching a
satellite would cost him between 50
million dollars and 400 million dollars
all on his own while we don't work for
NASA we're going to guess sir
considering that satellites need the
added capability of launching Veronica
back to earth at a moment's notice
Veronica's cast would be closer to the
high end of the estimate in 2017 the
same year Tony acted as Peter Parker's
father figure in spider-man homecoming
the billionaire got some good news from
a new estimate of his spending needs
according to a video made by coinage
timings personal finance video company
being Iron Man would cost eight point
four billion dollars a one point six
billion dollar drop from money
supermarket coms 2013 estimate of ten
billion dollars coinage his explanation
isn't nearly as comprehensive as far
breaking down and Safie how they arrived
at that number so it's curious how that
1.6 billion dollars went missing will
leave someone with tony stark level
intelligence or such that one else but
the most likely reason for this
discrepancy someone hasn't been keeping
up with the MCU movies shame shame sits
it's embarrassing as comprehensive as
any of the analyses of Tony Stark's cost
maybe there's a lot missing they one
knows for example the cost of the Spider
Man suits Tony makes the Hulkbuster suit
most of the 42 suit had made by Iron Man
3 or the automated arms used to peel the
armor off we don't know what age of
Ultron Zion Legion casts a new
nanofibers suit Tony debuts an infinity
war or the time machine in endgame
then there are personnel costs Tony has
to pay for all the food and other
amenities provided for the Avengers at
their compound not to mention that he
presumably pays him salaries he's got
quinjets and helicopters he's got
multiple satellites
he buys a giant stuffed bunny for pepper
and I'm on three and also he has to pay
for that dude's phony smashes after he
threatens the Mandarin
dummy then there's maintenance you think
Tony can build one of these insanely
advanced Iron Man suits and not bother
with tuneups every high-tech thing Tony
inventors and ongoing investments so
it's arguably fortunate they usually get
destroyed after only a couple of uses
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos but your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the pal so
you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]